MANO MARKS: Hi, I'm Mano
Marks, Developer Advocate
on the Google Maps API team.
This is the second
video in a series
of four designed to show you how
to get started with the Google
Maps JavaScript API.
In the first episode
of the series,
we covered creating and
customizing your first map.
In this episode, we'll
cover creating an API key.
Using an API key enables you to
monitor your application's Maps
API usage and ensure that
Google can contact you
about your application,
if necessary.
If your application's Maps API
usage exceeds the usage limits,
in a very rare
condition, you must
load the Maps API using
an API key in order
to purchase additional quota.
To get an API key, visit the
Google API console at this URL.
If necessary, log into
your Google account.
A quick note about
which account to use.
If you're planning to use the
map for your own personal use
and it'll always
be in your control,
you can go ahead and
use your own account.
However, if you're
planning to use it
for an organization
you work for,
consider using a
shared Google account
that other people can access.
That way, if you're no longer
working on the Maps project
or you aren't available
for some reason,
others can access the account
and receive any notifications
that might be necessary.
You can also accomplish
this by sharing the project
with others.
But the ownership of the account
and ownership of the project
should probably
stay with the map.
That's doubly true
if you're creating
the map for a customer.
To create a key, either
select an existing project
or create a new one.
To create a new project,
select the project list
and click on Create Project.
After you load or
create a project,
click on the Services tab.
Then scroll down to
Google Maps API v3
and click the button
to turn it on.
Finally, click on
the API Access tab.
Then click on the
Create New Browser key.
You should see this
box asking for domains.
Put the domains that you'll be
using for this Maps API key.
This will prevent others
from using the API
key on their sites.
OK, that's all there is to it.
In the next video, we'll
cover using the API key
when you load the JavaScript
API and the basic parameters
of the JavaScript loader.